evacuados por las autoridades rusas y
evacuados por las autoridades ucranianas
los servicios de emergencia de ambos
países siguen sacando a personas
afectadas por las inundaciones tras la
destrucción de la presa de Nova kahozca
los dos gobiernos se acusan de la
destrucción y de bombardear a civiles
durante la evacuación pero una supuesta
grabación revelada por la inteligencia
ucraniana señala que la destrucción de
la presa fue causada por un grupo de
Sabotaje ruso Más allá de culpables
miles de personas han perdido todo
incluso a sus seres queridos
el agua subía muy rápido pudimos haber
sacado a nuestra hija pero el agua subió
muy rápido en un torrente lo sumergió
todo el agua pasaba por un agujero a la
cocina de la cocina a la terraza
Mientras tanto los combates no cesan y
Ucrania intensifica sus acciones son
imágenes de boronés en Rusia donde un
drone atacó a un edificio de civiles
este otro vídeo muestra las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas destruyendo
equipamiento ruso cerca de bajo mud y en
este un ataque aéreo ruso contra
chercasi con varios heridos el
Ministerio de defensa ruso dijo haber
matado más de 1000 soldados ucranianos y
repelido ataques de una contraensiva
sobre la que Ucrania guarda silencio
esto el mismo día en el que el
presidente de Rusia Vladimir Putin se
reunió con su contraparte de velarus
Alexander lucasenco y anunció el
despliegue de armas nucleares
todo va según lo planeado el 7 u 8 de
julio serán los preparativos para las
instalaciones nucleares correspondientes
y comenzaremos las actividades
relacionadas con el despliegue del tipo
de armas correspondientes en belarus de
una vez
una escalada en el conflicto que
coincide con una contraofensiva
ucraniana que desde Estados Unidos
aseguran que ya está en marcha